It might be the oldest profession,
but prostitution and other forms
of sex work are also among the most
prohibited and heavily regulated
around the world.
At the latest Reason Speakeasy,
a monthly live event in New York
City with outspoken defenders of
free speech and heterodox thinking.
I talked with Kaytlin Bailey, the
founder and head of Old Pros,
a sex worker rights group, and
the writer and performer of Whore's
Eye View, a one-woman show
about 10,000 years of prostitution,
female emancipation, and
sexual freedom.
Bailey and Old Pros seek not just to
decriminalize sex work, but
to destigmatize it, too,
arguing that sex workers across
the centuries have not only provided
a much in-demand service but
helped to push the boundaries of
freedom and liberty.
Kaytlin, thanks for joining us.
Thank you so much for having me.
So let's get started by talking
about what is Old Pros.
Yeah, Old Pros is a nonprofit media
organization and we are focused on
creating the conditions to change
the social and legal status of sex
workers. And we believe
that by changing the story,
we can change laws and policies.
Okay. So it's magical thinking.
A little bit, yes.
You know, policy flowing downstream
of culture and narrative change.
You know, it's.
What what are your activities?
Well, we produce a ton of content,
so we produce the Old Pros
profession podcast where we
partner with professional historians
and do a deep dove on different sex
workers from history.
This has been a really powerful
tool for reminding folks, especially
legislators, that sex workers have
always been contributing members
of communities.
I have a one-woman
show side of you that
is a 75-minute
lecture covering 10,000 years
of history from a sex worker's
perspective.
We've produced
a ton of one-pagers and talking
points that we widely distribute
amongst allied organizations,
and we host events.
We had our first live event
last night, The Old Pro Show,
and I'm thrilled to announce that we
sold out.
That's great. All right, you've sold
out. You, man. You sold all the
tickets?
Yeah, we sold all the tickets.
Yes. I guess prostitutes, like.
Like rock or. They're not rock
stars. They don't mind selling out.
Well, I mean, I guess the point.
Is, it is sex for money, for sure.
Yeah, but, you know, some people do
that to avoid selling.
That's right. Okay.
So let's talk about the
Old Pros are the
Oldest Profession podcast.
When you say talk about history,
you know who is the most recent
guest and what were you talking
about?
Sure. So we cover old pros
from history. So we don't have
guests yet. But we we hope to do
that next season. We talk mostly
about dead people, but we covered
Lizzie Lape, who was this incredible
prolific madam in Ohio.
She ran a network
and she she was really the one of
the first generations, a
member of the first generation of
women to be able to keep
their property after
a divorce. And so she was able to
build her empire as an entrepreneur
and a sex worker.
This is 19th century.
Yeah, this is early, early 19th
century or she was born
she was a young child in the
beginning of the Civil War.
So late 19th Century.
Was prostitution legal then
or?
It's it's complicated.
Sex work wasn't criminalized
in this country until the
progressive era.
We criminalized, you know,
prostitution, alcohol, and abortion
actually all of the same.
Because each leads to the next.
Yes. That that was the theory.
Many.
It's not a bad theory.
Yeah.
It's yeah.
Sorry to do a because
abortion and contraception is almost
as old as the oldest profession.
It's actually it is interesting.
They they do go together as sex
workers have been sharing knowledge
about how to both encourage and
limit pregnancy for literally
all of human history.
When when we talk about
sex work.
Can you because I know this will
come up.
There's a you know, when we talk
about drug legalization, we talk
about mostly about legalization, not
decriminalization when
we talk about sex work.
Decriminalization and legalization
are different, distinct things.
Can you just lay that out before we.
Yeah. I think the big difference
between, you know, drugs and sex
workers is that, you know, sex
workers are service providers.
We're not commodities.
So, you know, we can't be governed
and regulated in the same way.
And so what we found with
legalization, it actually
really reduces the negotiating power
of providers and doesn't
lead to good results.
In Nevada, I think is the best
example. It's the only state in the
country with legal, regulated
prostitution, and it has the highest
arrest rate per capita
for prostitution-related offenses.
So can you walk through that,
though? In Nevada, there's
one or two counties that allow?
There are there are few rural
counties. The rule is that any
county with more than 700,000
residents.